this is a production of cornell
university
good morning everyone it's good to be
here if invoice only and what i'd like
to do today is talk to you a little bit
about usda blueberry breeding both here
in the northeast and around the country
there's a lot to talk about so we'll
begin our whirlwind tour
the first thing i'd like to talk about
are the usda blueberry breeding sites
there are three of them
chatsworth new jersey where i work doing
breeding primarily for the northeast but
also doing a little bit of breeding of
all different kinds
poplarville that does breeding primarily
for the southern regions
and corvallis which
does berry breeding of all sorts
blueberries cane berries strawberries
now the other thing that point i'd like
to make with this slide
is that in this day and age if you look
around the country and around the world
there are at least 29 other public and
private breathing programs worldwide
and the one point i'd like to make
particularly about the materials being
produced by these
is that at least for the usda at this
point in time
all the materials produced are public
domain
there are some exceptions specialty
cultivars
may or may not be patented
but they are public domain and i think
this is important
because it means that these cultivars
are readily available to everyone
they can be propagated readily they can
be sold readily
if you look at both private programs and
other public programs
they often have patented cultivars
and in some cases they are proprietary
and club cultivars meaning that
cultivars are not available to everyone
everywhere
what i'd like to look at with this
slider traits of importance to breeders
now this was a survey that was done in
2014
and if we look at this we can see that
some of the traits are seasonality
some of them are traits of importance to
growers
some of them are traits of importance to
consumers
but
amongst them what is rated highest is
productivity
and if you look to the right of the
slide in most cases
machine harvestability particularly in
this day and age is considered a
critical factor
now beyond this breeders select for many
many more things
things such as vigor
time of bloom
bush stature
self-fertility
so a breeder going out into the field
has to select for many many
factors some of them tangible some of
them intangible which takes us to our
next slide
marker assisted selection using
molecular markers is a strategy being
employed in every major crop today
the usda has engaged a group at cornell
to do the same thing
for several minor crops including
blueberry
and what this will ultimately do
is allow
us to predict the traits and performance
of an individual before it's ever grown
in the field
i'm not a molecular biologist
but the basic process of marker assisted
selection is not difficult to understand
in the development process we need to
determine the traits of interest
we then need to find a
segregating test population
that will be evaluated for those traits
of interest
and concurrently begin molecular marker
discovery
for the plants that are put into the
field each individual is scored for each
trait in multiple years
and ultimately correlation is made of
the molecular markers that are
discovered
and the traits that are tabulated for
each individual
when put into practice
whole populations can be screened and
individuals selected based upon the
markers that they express
or
as is being done nowadays in
limited cases in many many crops
is a selection of optimized parents
if you have optimized parents you can
produce and improve population more
readily than
unoptimized parents
what this allows you to do it allows you
to leverage your effort
but in all these cases the plants are
still going to need field testing
now when you look at molecular marker
assisted selection
it is especially good for complex traits
where the inheritance is not simple and
not easily traced
and it's also very good for traits with
sporadic expression or with genotype by
environment interactions
once again in any case it should save
considerable time effort and cost
now i'd like to move to conventional
blueberry breeding
the usda has produced cultivars over the
years that have been the backbone of the
blueberry industry
and the usda continues to produce
cultivars
for many needs in many areas what i'd
like to highlight here is a recent
release of ours from last year talisman
this is a northern high bush blueberry
variety
basically in a jersey season
if you look at it and think it looks
like a beautiful bush
that is what talisman looks like when it
grows this is a five-year-old bush of
talisman
i won't talk a lot about it here but i
would refer you to
um
contact me if you want more information
on it it's also been written up in
several different places and you can
certainly find it on the internet
to highlight a few further varieties
biloxi is a variety that was released in
1998 at a public domain variety
it has become a widely grown
variety in areas where no chill southern
hybris bush are needed
miniblues is processing variety and
again it's a specialty variety
it's a patented variety was released in
2017
it's a high quality fruit with
outstanding flavor and is as productive
as blue crop
but only half the size of the fruit
pink lemonade is a specialty variety we
released in 2007 this is also public
domain
pink lemonade is a rabbit eye derived
type variety so it's a little more
southern adapted but it is the most
successful pink fruited cultivar that's
been released so far
and in terms of looking at specialty
cultivars it has a unique
mild flowery flavor we continue to work
on pink varieties and i think they will
produce or find a larger niche
in the future
now in the last slide i casually
mentioned rabbit eye
my predecessor when i started working
suggested that we try to incorporate
more rabbit eye
for northern areas
and i took his comment to heart
one of the great things about rabbit eye
that always interested me is the great
vigor of rabbit eye what you can see on
the left hand picture
is rabbit eye seedlings and high bush
seedlings out in the field these are
young plants they're about two years old
and the rabbit seedlings are about twice
as tall
as the high bush seedlings
rabbit eye has the potential to get very
very large
if it grows
under ideal conditions but it does have
a lot of cons
it's not cold hardy it's late ripening
and it needs cross pollination
so one of the things we did over the
years was mix rabbit eye with some
northern germplasm
and my goal was to produce a blue
fruited variety for the north that might
be a little bit late ripening
and we partway succeeded
we produced a variety called nocturne it
has dark fruit
but
we did achieve cold hardiness
we did achieve self-fertility and we
maintained a lot of the vigor
now nocturne became a patented variety
for us
as a specialty ornamental and landscape
type plant
one of the important things to see
particularly about nocturne
is the cold hardiness that we achieved
in this material
if you look at the graph
what you can see this is a plot of cold
hardiness
of several different kinds of cultivars
legacy is a southern high bush tiff blue
is a rabbit eye
blue crop is northern high bush
by december 20th
if you look at cold hardiness the cold
hardiness of southern high bush and
rabbit types begin to decline
and move towards warmer and warmer
temperatures
northern however such as
blue crop
after december 20th
maintains a sort of a steady state of
dormancy for about another three or four
weeks
before it begins to lose dormancy
and because of the things we mixed with
rabbit eye and producing nocturne we
have produced a rabbit eye type plant
that stays
dormant
and cold hardy nearly as cold hardy as
northern high bush for the same amount
of time
and doesn't begin to deacclimate
until about the 7th of february
so in an ongoing project to try and
produce
northern adapted rabbit eye derived
plants
we have parents
that are not turned by duke and nocturne
by elliot
which we have in the field as vigorous
plants
and we have crossed those
to both high bush plants uh elliott and
duke in this particular case
as well as blue fruited
rabbit types powder blue
a couple of numbered selections
and also to nocturn again as well
and we currently have populations out in
the field that we will
be evaluating this summer
for both their growth
their productivity
their color
and their fruit quality
and i hope i i have some high
expectations for these materials and
we'll find out what particular sorts of
combinations
work out best in producing a commercial
product
and as my last topic i'd like to talk a
little bit about some new germplasm
we've been working to incorporate with
high bush blueberry
and that's a species called the indian
blueberry from south america also known
as vaccidium meridian alley
and the question is what does it bring
to the party why did we start using it
um what you see there is a picture of
vaccinium meridia meridian alley in its
native habitat
it brings a very dense floral structure
with a high flower number
it has a relatively uniform and
concentrated blooming period which is
something you'd want
for
machine harvesting
monopodial
also good for
machine harvesting tree-like structure
vigor
also and high antioxidants
um
[Music]
very much pigment in the skin
possibilities of internal pigmentation
cold arness perhaps some high altitude
adaptation
overall a vigorous and interesting plant
in
highly fertile also tetraploid so
potentially compatible with high bush
blueberry
in this picture we see the fruit of the
andean blueberry in the upper
photo in the center photo and the right
hand photo we see both the dense flower
structure
and the tall upright vigorous quality
that's inherited in the f1
and by the time we get to a back cross
one which is three quarters high bush
we've recovered blue fruit and pretty
decent-sized fruit as well
so
this is a actually a very successful
cross overall in terms of germplasm
incorporation and has a lot of potential
for future development
of
blueberry varieties
and so we were able with relative ease
to cross the tetraploid and be indian
blueberry
oh
i'm sorry
i'm just going to
start again
i'm so sorry
uh yeah play from curtin's nice
and so we were able with relative ease
to cross the tetraploid and be indian
blueberry with tetraploid high bush
blueberry produce vigorous
fertile and productive hybrids
what we also discovered along the way
was that we could cross the andean
blueberry with both cranberry and
lingonberry as well
and this really
is a project that i've dabbled with on
the edges for many many years and it's
an aspiration that really has turned
into a reality
and once you know that you can do this
it's easy when you think about the
various vaccinium crops
traits in one crop or the other that
would be useful if they could be moved
into one of the other crops
this slide summarizes our current
progress on crossing meridian alley with
the other vaccinium species
any place you see a picture
we've succeeded in making the cross
if it's the blob box is shaded or blank
it's a cross that is either in the works
or still needs to be done but what i'd
like to emphasize about this
is that
not only have we been able to make these
crosses if they're made between plants
that are both at the same employee level
we can generate many hybrids not just a
few hybrids but hundreds of hybrids
fairly easily
and in all the cases we've looked at so
far
the initial hybrids have been quite
fertile
that crosses to
the species are
a mixed bag sort of some are are
somewhat difficult some are more uh
difficult than others
all the crosses to lingenberry are
crosses between a tetraploid and a
diploid which is is not a naturally easy
cross you'd normally want to be crossing
at
a
dip
say employee level
but what i can say is this
once you get beyond that first
generation and into the second
generation you can then begin permuting
these crosses any which way and crossing
um
sort of sideways amongst these different
hybrids um and i think this really has
the potential not only to improve or
allow the transfer of traits among these
different crops
but also to potentially
produce new crops um think of things
like apriums and plus which are hybrids
of of apricots and plums this may not be
any different
so with that i'd like to close
um if anyone has any questions about any
of these materials feel free to contact
me
at either the email listed or the phone
number listed
i can give you much more information
about new and upcoming varieties if
you're interested i'd also recommend if
you haven't seen it and want to know
more about blueberries and the blueberry
industry
the u.s high bush blueberry council has
a weekly podcast
called the business of blueberries
it's uh
web web address is listed there
tune in is a good thing
thank you very much
and i'll be available for
all
questions
thank you so much mark what a thrilling
and exciting presentation
oh my jaw is just dropping when you said
that about
the possibility to cross blueberries
with
so many other
vaccinium crops it just
that's so incredible
and so we have a couple
questions um
and i believe we have a little bit of
time to answer them
um
thank you uh laura is asking about
southern high bush and their ability to
do quite well in northern hardiness
zones uh
down to zone four um there are a number
of growers succeeding with a few
southern high bushes in laura's service
area
and she's wondering if you have any
comments on that
well you know
it'd be interesting to for me to know
exactly what varieties they're using
because there are some of the southern
high bush that have more hardiness than
others and even if we look at newer
releases of northern high bush a lot of
them have small
uh
uh bits of germplasm from from that are
as southern in ancestry
um
what i've always believed and i'm i'm
pretty sure if you go back to that the
one graph i had about rabbit eye in
there is that for anything that's
southern
um it the the wintertime cold hardiness
is not the biggest issue the the biggest
issue is them emerging from dormancy too
early and flowering too early
so among things that have southern high
bush in their background
if they are relatively slow to break
dormancy and slow to flower
um there's potential for them to do well
if there's something that blooms earlier
and that's the case with many of the the
southern high bush that you bring up to
this area
they are much more likely to get injured
at least in some years where we might
have late freezes of course
things are getting warmer over the
winter so
you know
the answer is some might do well others
not so much it depends on where you are
and uh what the relative winter is like
thank you
and uh tony emmy has added that uh he's
growing blue crop blu-ray and patriot
uh at his farm just below lake ontario
in new york
um well those are all northern high bush
and and quite hardy
you sound like good choices for that
area
um and so folks i think y'all should
keep writing your questions into the
chat and mark would you be okay to stay
on and maybe answer any other questions
that oh
absolutely i can hang on as long as
needed later on thank you so much it's
so good to have you here
um and
now um we're going to have our next
speaker who is uh thierry bazancon
and
he will be speaking to us
about wheats
so
dr thierry bezanzon
is an extension specialist in wheat
science
he works with specialty crops
and he works at the philip e marucci
center for blueberry and cranberry
research and extension in new jersey
so one of his many projects is examining
alternative weed management strategies
that may help reduce the potential for
herbicide resistance
in specialty crops
and without further ado i am inviting
uh dr eben song to share his screen
of
yeah good morning everyone so thanks
sonia for this introduction
i'm a colleague of mark from ellenfeld
who just took uh before we're working in
the same resource station in the pine
lands of new jersey and i'm i'm working
on wheat science in so many different
crops um but today we'll be focusing on
on blueberry on ibush blueberry better
yes it's better
yes so in new jersey i mean uh new
jersey is basically the home of two
vaccine species um
one is northern irish blueberry uh which
has been uh developed uh at the
beginning of the
twentieth century in new jersey by
elizabeth coleman white
and we are also the home of
another vacuum species which is large
cranberry
um new jersey is ranking six for
blueberry production nationally
on
third for cranberry production so we are
really focused on vaccine species
in new jersey
um
so in our state modern blueberry
cropping is really conducted on some
dissolve so our soils are extremely
sandy uh i would say at least 85 percent
some
most of the soil are over 95 percent sun
content
uh
many situations we are relatively low to
moderate organic matter
and we are we are really observing a
depletion issue over the years
um and i will come back later
why is that the case um our blueberries
are planted on ill
most of the growers switch to drip tape
irrigation
which
may be good for disease management but
it's not so good for for weed management
and i can explain that a little bit
later
most of the growers are using
cultivation for maintaining wheat free
raw meters
we have very few growers using uh cover
crops or sod between the rows
um on the the hill are really maintained
with either herbicide or merge for for
weed for weed management
so berries are very i wish blueberry are
very sensitive to wheat competition and
one of the reasons is that you already
have an open soil
you have a lot of light
newly planted
field
you have continuous irrigation which was
a problem that i was mentioning before
but with strictly irrigation you're
providing a constant flow of water which
is extremely uh important for
stimulating the germination of weeds as
well as uh you know
forcing the herbicide that you may be
using to run off um on pushing there
beside deeper on the ground where it may
not be effective at preventing uh seeds
to germinate or to emerge so this
condition will facilitate the
development of weed as much as a crop
on the picture before is it's an organic
field and you can see the magnitude of
weed issues that we may have in some of
our fields here in new jersey
so
these days you're really relying on
integrated weed management for managing
weeds and that's really the combination
of multiple meters on practice for
managing weeds so you're trying to
combine
uh prevention i mean everything is based
on prevention we'll spend some time
there really discussing prevention for
weed management but we are trying to
combine cultural mechanical and chemical
approach for already optimizing our
re-management uh and there is a good
reason why we do that um
you may have heard of the rapid spread
of herbicide resistance not only in
agronomy crop but also in specialty
crops including blueberry so when you
have these herbicide resistant wheats
obviously you need to have other tactics
for controlling them you may have new
species entering the field
that will require
tactics different than just
using herbicides and you have an
increase associated amount for less for
less herbicide
used in
crop production
so the very easy basics i said it but uh
the basics is really prevention and to
do that even before starting to plant
your you know even um
before working your blueberry field when
you're at the stage of planning your
plantation you need to really um to
release things to what you will be doing
especially with regard to weed
management so you you need to start
clean and you need to stay clean
um so for berries on other planet crops
you really need to be carefully choosing
the sides where you will be planting
your blueberry field you want to avoid
as much as possible and it's not always
possible i am whatever that but you want
to avoid as much as possible any field
where you have a problematic personal
species such as binary kinetico
goldenrod uh eventually nutsedge uh
because i mean if you really don't want
to have problems with these sweets later
during your production cycle you need to
be able to manage them really
aggressively before planting
because you're really very few options
that will be effective at controlling
this kind of weight when when you're
filled with being production
um so one one option is really to uh to
to use cultivation um ahead of time
before planting your blueberry
on that tree i mean the principle then
cultivation is that you really want uh
to force the weed to exhaust any energy
which is stored in the underground parts
um in in you know in the rhizome in the
roots um and by doing that on by
preventing the weed to to um to grow uh
you may really
force far away to um to exhaust all the
energy stored in the underground uh
storage uh parts uh if you want to do
that you need to really cultivate every
seven to fourteen days any gap if you're
if you're missing any you know any
cultivation that will provide fish on
time for the weed to grow on to
respiration nutrients back to the roots
so basically you would be back uh you
would be back
at you know you would be back to the to
the beginning of your cultivation
because you will
not have make any progress
um in terms of disturbance can be
problematic with respect to sutures or
else on the potential for erosions
um and as i mentioned infrared
disturbance can result in root and
rhizome fragments
on bulbs being spread throughout the
field and become established that's
especially the case with species like
canada distal
that can really re-root themselves
easily if you're just fragmenting the
rhizome which is what you're doing when
you're doing calculation
so another option is really to to try to
use some systemic post emergence heavy
side that can really help you
controlling some of these spinal species
so the two main herbicides that we're
using for that for preparing the field
first one is glyphosate and we are all
we can also use 240.
with this herbicide the best application
timing is ready when the plants are in
bed or flowers
and for most of these places you will
have to renew the herbicide application
in fall before frost for maximizing the
amount of herbicide then can be sent
back uh to the rhizome of the of this
perennial plants
um as i mentioned you really want to
plan ahead of time at least two years
because some of this perennial weed it
will take at least two three years if
you really want to get to achieve
success in controlling these weeds um
and you have to be aware that some
perennial weeds for example
yellow nutsedge will not be effectively
controlled even glyphosate if you look
at the graph on the right side uh even
glyphosate is not considered an optimal
episode for containing nutsedge it may
have some effect but definitely you will
not prevent a tuber production with with
glyphosate on 240 has absolutely no
effect on the other such so some of the
spaniel
you may have to deal with them later
during the cropping cycle of your
blueberries but it's um it's really hard
to to control them before planting the
field
um you need to be aware that um as
humans who are moving a lot of weeds in
on out of production environments so
true equipment that you are using
or in some situation
when we are introducing uh wigs with
with mulch in our situation at the
station we have some field where we use
a cranberry leaf mulch and we introduce
a specific weed of cranberry bugs which
is carolina redwood
we know it it came with a merch
so preventing weeds on dispersing is a
critical integrated weed measuring
practice
so ready cleaning equipment when you're
moving equipment between feed is
especially critical
especially if you have herbicide
resistant wheats you want to make sure
that you're not introducing to
introducing them to fields that are
that are free of herbicide resistant
weeds
you need to make sure that you're
sourcing uh wheat free mulch or compost
natural mulches
um if you're using cover crop um you you
need to make sure that your cover crop
seeds are free of wheat seeds
and a good technique is also making sure
that you're not just controlling the
weeds within the field but pay attention
to what's going on around the field
clearly if you have a situation where
you have a lot of perennial weeds or
other type of wheats around your
blueberry field that may be a perfect
situation for for getting some seeds
moving into your field later so try to
control
these weeds around the field as well
know your enemy um the really really
notification it's it's a it's also a
critical uh part of um of integrated
wind management and it's essential for
developing a successful management plan
one of the reasons for that is that not
order beside our equals on herbicide
will work really well on some species
while not working while not working on
some other species
um the life cycle and growth stage of a
weed will largely determine optimum
timing of control measures so for a
quick example if you're looking at
grasses if you have animal grasses like
large crabgrass the best time to really
control this one either mechanically or
with herbicide is really to target
annual grasses when they are young and
actively growing
know if you're doing if you're dealing
with crack grass which is a planet of
grass
this one uh i mean the best time is the
best strategy is really to deplete food
reserve in underground vegetative
structures so that's that's what we're
trying to target
um a different different website that
i've been listing here and i think the
presentation will be available for you
so a few websites where you can have
help identifying weeds um
something that we are still using and
that should be updated this year is a
wheat of the northeast guide it's a it's
a it's a kernel guide on um
tony de tomas what kernel is in the
process of of working on a new version
of the guide because we have new weeds
that came in the northeast region but
the guide right now is still available
on the carmel website
um the last thing that you can really do
as well is if you if you have a phone
there is two apps i naturally stand on
plantnet that can be used for for
helping you with recognition
identification of weeds in the field
so basically both apps are using a
recognition software to compare your
picture to image galleries and provide
you with an identification
a few recommendations on how to use
these apps as they are relying on unique
morphological characteristics on flowers
and
so that will improve uh your eyelid char
your chance of eye of identifying the
weeds if you can really
have flowers or have very specific
features like the leaf shape or things
like that
that are really
clear on your picture
um you need to make sure that your
picture are clear on minimized
background and you need to submit a
multiple picture for really getting a
positive notification
one cavity is that i will say that even
if you have a clear identification if
you have time try to double check your
wheel id with reputable source talk to
your contact function agents to make
sure that you really identify
with
properly detecting weed that's another
really important part of any
weed management program
um just want to remind you that the
relative emergence of values wheat
species is spreading throughout the
season here's some wheat species that
will emerge in fall
or sweet for example is a good case
when we have mild winter or swede will
keep emerging and keep growing during
the winter
on in what we are considering a summer
annual weed
we have some species that may really
start emerging relatively early in the
in the season uh lum's quarter is a good
example of a weed that will start
emerging probably in late march earlier
parade in in new jersey and you have
some other species such as fall panicum
crab grass or even goosebumps that will
be mostly considered as lace spring
early summer emerging weeds so you have
to keep in mind that yes i mean it's you
have all these wheat species and if you
have a dominant wheat species in your
field um knowing what time this weed is
emerging is a really good strategy for
optimizing your uh your management
tactics either using mechanical control
or using
herbicides
so when we are scouting for weeds
usually we are we are doing two to three
steps per acre we are working along 30
feet of row uh to to um to look for the
weeds we are trying to spread out
something area for getting a really
representative map of the wheat
infestation
on at each stop we are looking at
what are the wheat species what are the
stage of of development on what is the
density of the wheat species we are not
counting them it is just low moderate or
really high density of wheat species
spaces
be mindful that with some in some
situation you may have clustering um
area in your field you may have
condition
you know in the field that will
stimulate the development of the
specific wheat species uh and try always
to bring a camera with you for for
really confirming identification later
um so now that you did this work of you
know uh finding the weed and change the
weed what can we do so i will start with
you know mechanical we control and
discuss some of those options that that
are available available to us um the
first one is really using some organic
roamers
so it's mostly we're using mostly pine
bark
in new jersey
so this much will really help with
preventing the emergence of annual weeds
not so much with perennial weeds
it's really hard to stop nutsedge to
grow even if you're putting a five or
six inches layer of pine bark mulch
they're really helpful for for um with
moisture retention on on prevention of
soil erosion
in our situation in new jersey they are
also all helpful because they allow us
to increase organic
organic matter content over time
now one of the problems that we have
with some of these mulch is that
because they have such a high carbon to
nitrogen ratio
they may
they may be responsible for separation
of crop growth because when you're
applying fertilizer when you're applying
nitrogen fertilizer
basically the mulch will absorb the
fertilizer to
rebalance basically the carbon nitrogen
ratio on starter degradation process of
the merch so the nitrogen will be bind
up to the merch and will not be
available uh for for for for
for your crops so you in some situation
or you really need if you do that you
really need to uh to bump your rate of
fertilizer to compensate for whatever
will be tied up to the merge
this type of merch are costly and in
some situations they can harbor wheat
seeds based on potentially harmful
diseases as well
so i mean some of the questions that i
got many times here in new jersey is
that how do you use herbicide on organic
much um so ready organic merch are
complicating the the use of of herbicide
because the mulch will absorb most of
the herbicide
so pre-emergent subside rate should be
increased to maximum labor rate for soil
with high organic matter content you
need i mean you will have some herbicide
i mean you have some regular weeds that
will still emerge through the mulch as i
mentioned earlier
on if you really want to be
efficient at controlling some of these
perennial weeds you really need to use
higher pre-emergence heavy side for
compensating for making sure some
herbicide will
reach the ground
a thick organic organic mulch will
suppress weeds emergence from under the
mulch mostly for annual wheat species
one of the issues that you may have with
organic mulch is that annual weeds
rooting in the surface of decomposed
mulch are the major problems so when the
merch is starting to decompose
it start to make a really
proper
like a putting mix if you want for weeks
to to germinate
um and as i mentioned organic merch is
definitely not solution for controlling
nutsedge which which is a major problem
for rc and new jersey and i will show
you a few pictures later
uh plastic merch that's not really used
here in new jersey we have just a few
growers who use it
um it's
same sting it's good for moisture
retention it's it's really good for salt
warming it can prevent some weed
emergence again not for yellowness
agilent search can easily pierce through
the plastic merge
um the problem is that it can be
expensive to purchase lay on disposed
off
on some people may have issue with the
production disposal of plastics
um
cultivation raw middle which is what we
are doing a lot here in new jersey and
we are trying to change that but it has
been it has been difficult
mostly because i we have sandy acidic
soil in new jersey which are not really
proper for developing cover crop or
thought crop we're working on that we're
training we have a program starting this
year looking at
finding
finding the proper saw that can be
really used for for um
for planting between the rows so
cultivation is great for improving water
penetration on increased
soil oxygen level it can really help by
eliminating eliminating a small wheat
seedlings
one of the major issues that we have
right now in new jersey that repeated
cultivation will contribute to decrease
uh to decrease organic matter through
oxidation or it will contribute to to
destroying the soil structure and that's
one of the reason why in new jersey
we came from maybe four or five percent
organic matter 30 40 years ago to less
than two percent organic matters um
these days and it starts to be a major
issue
also because when you have lower organic
matter content that will stimulate root
sensitivity to salt bone disease so
that's something that's a critical issue
that we have
this these days in new jersey
on reading is still done in some
situation um
mostly in organic blueberry field but we
don't have many of them here in new
jersey
uh in that situation i mean on weeding
with owing it's mostly done because you
can you don't have mechanical tools that
can effectively control
within the row it's good for controlling
between the row but within the row since
you have a hill it's really hard to get
a good mechanical control so people will
send a crew of of people for for owing
uh on the eel on one of the problems
that we observe with that is that if
people are not careful they can easily
start um uh unrooting the the blueberry
uh plant exposing the roots on creating
a lot of issues uh with that
uh suppressing wheat chemically and that
will be my my last um my last section
for today
um so we have different herbicide uh we
have um we have we are classifying them
uh in in many different ways one way is
to look at where are you applying the
herbicide so you have soil applied
there's just fourier applied heavy side
you have herbicides that are applied
prior to weed emergence what we are
calling the pres and we have herbicides
that are
applied after we dimensions what we're
calling the post energy the post
herbicide uh on you can also look at
what kind of readers are controlling so
they can be broad spectrum or they can
be neurospectrum they can be selective
or they can be for something besides
non-selective besides
um so we'll start with using release of
pre-emergent soil applied herbicide on a
few i like to remind that because it's
it's so easy to skip that and it's
really important to make sure that these
herbicides are are
functioning uh properly
so uh these herbicides need to apply in
full or spring before bird break
uh and it's critical and i will show you
a little bit later why this herbicide
will remain active in the soil for weeks
or months
not all herbicides are equally safe on
on berries
and some of them are only designated for
non-bearing plants
what is really critical is that you need
to start clean if you have any kind of
residues of wheat on the soil surface
that will act really as a screen for
preventing this
pre-emergence herbicide to get into the
ground they need to be into the ground
they need to be moving into the first
few inches of salt to be really
efficient if you have any residue the
salt surface
that will uh that that will reduce your
abi side effectiveness
you need to make sure that you're
adjusting the rate to soil type and
organic matter
um
spread coverage is is critical so you
need to have a uniform spray coverage as
much as possible
activation is required meaning that the
herbicide doesn't uh need to set the
surface of the soil this herbicide needs
to move into the first few inches of
soil to be really efficient meaning that
you need to get water when you apply the
premature service you probably need to
get water in the next five to seven ten
days after application you need at least
half an inch of water to make sure the
herbicide is penetrating into the ground
on is really efficient if you just start
at the surface of the ground it will
start to degrade because of uv light
and it will not be active
make sure that you're not disturbing
those ground after applying this
premature service side because any
disturbance will be an open area for
weeds to emerge
and as i mentioned earlier when you are
using drip irrigation you you may uh
reduce the the length of residual
control over time because you're washing
off the herbicide you're increasing the
wash off of the of this premature
service side so some pre-emergent
service side that i've um i
classified them depending on the kind of
weeds that they're controlling so this
one are mostly pre-emergent services
that are recommending for for
controlling grasses so they have
herbicides such as alliance
kept soliciting ceo from velpar
no please know that alien and velpa
are
also good for annual uh broadly species
for die cuts they are not just good for
grasses they are also good for die-cuts
they are not so so good on perennial
grass uh weeds those are really greater
besides for annual wheats
i had gallery ian you just said but i
realized it's not labeled for use in in
new york so do not apply gary in new
york at all
same classification but this time
looking at broadly species die-cuts um
uh we have heavy sites such as callisto
casserone chateau
uh
karmix princep sinba solida we are not
using a lot of simba in new jersey
mostly because in our sunday soil it can
be extremely detrimental to the plant we
we can have a lot of
phytotoxicity
especially if you're using a high rate
of simba so
growers do not tend to use simba a lot
in new jersey a lot of growers are using
camex on princep and will mix it with
one of the grass herbicide
solid cam most of the time or eventually
definitely
a note that i didn't get but surf lan uh
which is a grass pre-emergent
grasshopper side doesn't seem to be
available
uh in 2022 maybe not before 2023 we will
have syrfron available
again
looking at some of these herbicides so
that was an experimentation we conducted
at the mercy center for three years so
you're looking at an untreated uh block
where you can see a lot of grasses a lot
of sages are on some goldenrod which is
a perennial
perennial weed
so we used alion
in fall the previous year and you're
looking at the data in in july of the
following year
on we still had i mean alien was really
great even if you applied it the produce
fall except for search control so what
you see green in the island picture
already sages uh casserone was a great
premature service when applied in fall
but i would not think i i think i didn't
still be doing a better job especially
for grasses um compared to casserole our
best results were already when we're
using a three-way mix of carmex callisto
on surflan applied in spring that's
where we got the best result in terms of
weight control especially looking at
search control which is a big problem at
the station we really got excellent
result mixing these three episodes
together
mostly because when you're mixing carmex
which is a photosystem travis site on
callister which is an uh hppd heavy side
you're getting some synergistic activity
uh when you're mixing the two together
so they're really great for for a broad
leave on search controller and when
you're adding syrflam to the mix or
different grass on this side you're
really getting good control of grasses
as well
a quick update on some things that we
that happened with herbicide in 2017 so
we observed a lot of injury on blueberry
in 2017
looking at stunting roses resetting of
the food and that was a major problem
for us in new jersey and when we look at
what the growers were doing we we asked
progress to provide the special
application request
something that was spot on was that all
the growers who got this kind of issue
on their plant had applied
pendimethaline
prowl herbicide um
in in this field on on some of the
problems that we had with spending metal
in that make this issue with that
growers using pendimethalin with late
application with regard to crop
phenology so really important to apply
pre-emergent services before bud break
so we're using the highest labor rate
especially if you look at our soil
texture in new jersey we have already
some disorder with organic matter so
that's provide you the full shot of
herbicide when you are applying
herbicide on the ground on our
blueberries i already have shallow root
system so that was kind of good recipe
for forgetting issue especially because
we had such late application
on what bendy metalline is doing is that
it's it's really um an herbicide which
is absorbed by the roots on that will
prevent the development of fine
airy roots fine feeding roots if you
want so i took this picture i i dig up i
dig up some plants looking at plants
that have been treated with spendy
metalline on looking at plants that are
not treated with spendy metal in
clearly the picture really it really is
really impressive to see how bendy
metalline
really uh prune all the feeding roots uh
out of the
blueberry rooting
system so basically the symptoms that
you are looking on the bush we're mostly
due to the fact that the plant was not
able to feed right mostly because we we
prune all this uh feeding small feeding
root uh when we are using a pendimeter
so this herbicide is not labeled anymore
for for use on blueberry um mostly
because of these issues that we saw in
2017 in jazza um two last slide so we're
using post emergence
for the episode as well so a few
recommendations looking at this
post-imagined service side
make sure you never let any
non-selective herbicide in contact with
green or living blueberry tissue
make sure that
if you have to use this non-selective
herbicide you can use protective sheets
around blueberry plants in new planting
because the new planting will be the
most
sensitive type of blueberry to these
post-emitting stone selective herbicide
and with post-emergent services with
size matter
wheats are best controlled when they're
relatively small so that's emphasize the
need for scouting really important
um be aware of herbicide resistant in
some weed species i know that for us in
new jersey or three is resistance is
really resistant to glyphosate so we
have difficulties controlling our swede
with glyphosate applied post emergency
it will not do the job
um post-emergent services may require
spread punk additives such as surfactant
to maximize control efficacy that's
mostly the case with brahminicide as the
herbicides that are targeting the
grasses
already optimus prevalence on
appropriate nozzle selection will be
really important on very among every
side so pay attention to the label when
you're using some of these post-emergent
service side
is what we have labeled here in new
jersey so we have some non-selective
herbicides such as m and gramoxone which
are strictly contacted besides they have
no
systemic systemic activity they will not
penetrate into the plant glyphosate is
really is it's a systemic design by
definition
really working great not just on annual
weeds but also for annual weeds as well
we have rely as well which has some
local systemicity greater besides but be
careful with this um
glyphosate or herbicide if you have new
canes you really want to make sure that
you're not applying this herbicide to
the nutrients because that may be a
perfect recipe for for killing
new canes and blueberry brushes
a few selective area sides so we have
the raminy side fusilae post select they
are really great for controlling annual
grasses
we have embed which is a low volatility
formulation of 240.
um
we are just starting to use it here in
new jersey and i'm concerned again with
potential injury to new canes and the
last one that i wanted to mention is
sandia that's basically our workhorse
for controlling yellow nutsedge which is
a big issue here in new jersey as i
mentioned really sandia is doing great
job controlling nutsedge
just to illustrate that that's a trial
we did in 2020
looking at the untreated check which is
really loaded with yellowness edge we
used sandia post-emergence uh when the
yellowness edge was at the two-leaf
stage two to three leaf stage only came
back
uh 45 days later with a second
application of sundia on really by the
end of the season we had excellent
control of here on that search so that's
really i like this heavy side mostly for
foreign search control because it's such
a tremendous problem here in new jersey
with that said i i don't know if we
still have time that's my last slide
it's um oh um i bruise blueberry read
management calendar schedule
and i i think it can be used in other
region as well so anya that was my
presentation and hopefully we still have
a little bit of time if we have any
questions from people
thank you so much that was just
so helpful i'll definitely be watching
the recording of this during the growing
season for us
there is a lot to cover on wind
management you know 30 minutes to talk
about weed management in blueberries
you really have to compress it
thank you so much and i think we don't
have much time for questions now but
would you be able to uh look at the chat
and answer any questions in the chat
yes of course no problem thank you so
much that would be wonderful
um because i'm really excited to
introduce our next speaker my wonderful
colleague laura mcdermott
um
laura are you there
so hello everyone thanks very much anya
for introducing us um liz mulchhoff and
i are going to kind of co-present this
uh
this topic
and i'm going to talk first about the
actual water quality issues and then liz
is going to handle the equipment issues
and we certainly will take i don't think
it'll take very much time and we'll try
to get through it so that we can
answer questions
so first of all and and let me preface
this is that this comes from
you know one of the greatest challenges
for us in the northeast where we have a
just a whole slew of different soil
types that we're trying to grow on
is that often our soil types are not
perfect for
blueberries and so that makes the soil
management a problem or a challenge and
then sometimes even the
the irrigation water can also be a bit
of an issue and that seems to be
um where
we're finding some solutions to kind of
languishing
uh blueberry
uh plantings that just don't have great
vigor and it seems like everything else
is done right and then we look at the
water and it's like holy cow we really
need to address this so
basically um the blueberries are in the
air casey family a family of heads and
they're true acid-loving plants your
target soil ph is four and a half we can
go up to 5.0 and they still can be
performed pretty well but 4.5 is our
target
and ideally they'd like just like um
terry just was mentioning a sandy
well-drained soil
preferably with a higher water table so
they can get access to water as as they
grow
but
that sandy soil is not always something
that we have available to us
if you have higher organic matter soils
oddly enough it
the ph can be a little bit higher
perhaps than 5.0 i've seen
excellent
uh plantings that the ph of the soil
seems to be around 5.5 but i think maybe
the way we're growing with lots of heavy
mulch
um and may and the acidification of the
soil as the mulch breaks down that might
actually be helping us to some degree
however
we cannot expect to grow a good vigorous
crop of blueberries uh high bush
blueberries if we're on poorly drained
or heavy soils especially if the cation
exchange capacity is high that's 18 or
above or if your calcium levels are
greater than 2 000 pounds per acre this
is not ideal blueberry soil
having said that i do have some growers
that have been able to combat uh
that high calcium levels
and the high cec levels
but it does take a lot of
a lot of work
so when we see higher ph in the soil
we often see iron deficiencies that
yellowing
um along with some other nutrient
deficiencies and sometimes we just see
poor vigor poor growth we don't see a
ton
of other obvious foliar problems but we
just don't see good growth and
so
pre-planning pre you know getting that
site
ready
it could take two years
um this is something that new growers do
not want to hear because
as you all know um it takes quite a
while before we get good
growth out of out of a planting but
and and yield but if you have to do two
or so extra years years in preparation
it's um
uh it's daunting but it's still worth it
and i do want to point out that
sometimes i can just tell or at least
get an idea of what our
cec is going to be just by looking at
the soil so a lot of times when we see
light colored sands we have really low
cation exchange capacity could be even
three to five
mil equivalents per hundred grams of
soil and that's what we usually call it
so
that it and then when we see maybe
darker colored loams and silt loams a
lot of times we'll see
uh cec in the 15 to 25 uh range mill
equivalents per 100 grams and organic
soils like mux oils can often have
cc of 50 to 100 so that's a kind of
breadth and if we're looking at having
an upper limit of about 18 that shows
you that a lot of our soils may not be
appropriate necessarily
the challenge is that sulfur is cheap
and blueberry fruit is worth a lot of
money so people are really interested in
growing blueberries on less than perfect
soils and this particular
picture is not mine it's actually um
from the
university of florida i do not think at
least i hope that that is not uh
elemental sulfur spread i think it's
probably mixed with something else but
the problem with applying sulfur to an
existing planting is that we are really
limited with how much sulfur can be
spread because sulfur can burn plants so
that's again going back to why it's so
important to get the site
prepped ahead of time
so let's talk about the water because if
you have done everything right and
you're working with that soil and you're
trying your best to
um keep the soil ph in that 4.5 to 5.0
range
and you still are struggling with plant
growth
and if you haven't tested your water
before this now's the time because
a lot of times we will have bicarbonates
and carbonates
in the water that can increase the salt
concentration and also
raise the ph of the water itself
and if your irrigation water is from a
well so you have a relatively consistent
source as far as the water quality
goes that can be a real problem
this can
it can decrease the nutrient
availability
most people have problems
resulting in plugging of irrigation
lines
calcification um just kind of jamming up
those lines if you're fertigating you
might notice this especially
and in extreme soil
in extreme
[Music]
you could see soil crusting we don't see
a lot of that thank goodness in my in
our region but certainly in the
southwest and the west where they have
alkaline soils this is a common
occurrence
and the only ways where you're going to
be able to figure out if you've got um
an issue is to actually do
water testing so
that that really is important
um you can do your own measurement aids
and this might at least give you give
you some ballpark information about
what your ph is
and some of these tools are
just um regular old ph uh strips and
sometimes people use pool strips uh they
can work and they're very helpful for
giving you a ballpark but
i have noticed that the pool strips are
very general they don't really target uh
they don't really hone down into the
kind of breadth of information that you
need so these color ph the color fast
strips and are the region the zone that
we're looking specifically for is the
4.0 to 7.0 ph range you can get them at
sanitation tools probably some other
suppliers carry them as well
and then some people rely on ph meters
which you can get very inexpensive ones
are very fancy ones but
as long as you've got something that you
know that are
reliable the problem with some of the
meters is that you have to continue to
recalibrate them and that can be a real
challenge for
farmers you just need to do that
probably several times a season
in making sure that they're calibrated
so here's an example of a little um
discussion about alkalinity alkalinity
doesn't necessarily mean
that your water is hard although that
sometimes it's used interchangeably but
basically it's the measure of the
calcium carbonate and the buffering
capacity
and so
if you have
low buffering capacity of less than
30 milligrams per liter of calcium
carbonate that
means that you can easily adjust
that ph of your sample
if you have higher than that higher than
100 milligrams per liter that means you
have high ph water which is also going
to be really hard to adjust so this is a
nice little image from penn state
um here we have a water sample that's
9.0 in both water sample a and b
on the left the total alkalinity is 75
milligrams per liter
so that means that in order to drop that
ph to where we want it to be you have to
add 10 drops
of acid in order to drop it down to 7.0
whereas if our alkalinity is only 25 we
only have to have one drop of acid in
order to drop that ph so alkalinity is
really important if you don't know what
your alkalinity is you cannot adjust
your
irrigation water ph
and here's just another chart from eric
smith at the university of georgia
that talks about these are upper limits
so this means these are the upper
thresholds for when you just cannot
tolerate anything more we would prefer
these amounts to be less
so it gives the um electrical
conductivity or the salinity
um that measure which we haven't really
talked about and but that's an important
water quality
measure the total dissolved solids which
actually can play into the hardness
not necessarily alkalinity but the
hardness and we want that that's a
fairly
250 to 640 parts per million
the ph again if your ph is over of your
water is over 6.0 then we want to do
something about that so measuring that
is important
it also gives um the upper limits of
bicarbonates of boron which can if boron
which is not usually a problem i've
never seen it a problem in
either surface water or well water
but if it's high it can cause some
problems toxicity problems with plants
and then of course chloride and sodium
which especially if you're using
municipal water supplies that
occasionally can be an issue
the other thing to keep in mind is that
surface water which is stream or river
or pond water if you're using that for
irrigation
that can vary widely wildly during the
growing season so
kind of constantly measuring that to
make sure that your
your water is where you think it is
especially if you're acidifying it
is going to be necessary and then
well water is more it is usually more
consistent however if we have droughts
or if you have a shallow well that can
change
too
um let's keep going and so what kinds of
acids do you need to use in order to
neutralize uh water alkalinity and these
are the four most
commonly used um phosphoric sulfuric
nitric and citric they have different
percent strengths
um the cost is also different for the
citric acid is quite a lot citric and
nitric acid actually are quite a lot
more expensive than phosphoric and
sulfuric
phosphoric and sulfuric sulfuric is
usually the cheapest
but the relative hazard of that is quite
high
you also with when you add acids you
also get some other
nutrients that come into the system and
for into your fertility program so you
could get quite a lot of sulfur quite a
lot of phosphorus quite a lot of
nitrogen that come in depending upon
what type of acid
you use
um
keeping in mind that acids are really
dangerous can be extremely dangerous
when you add acids to water you create
an enormous amount of heat that heat can
burn you it can burn your eyes so making
sure that you have safety glasses face
shields
rubberized
aprons and then acid resistant gloves
and boots when you are mixing this or
working with the acid is really really
important
you want to use the correct equipment
and liz will talk a little bit more
about this but containers and fittings
that don't corrode or resist the acid
when you mix acid with water you want to
make sure that you add
acid to the water not vice versa
and you want to fill that stock
container half full acid slowly is added
mixing well with trying to eliminate any
splashes and then you can continue to
kind of add
water to the
diluted mixture as you go and then
fertilizers should go in after the acid
both behind the mixing and then
incorporating them into that
acidification as is appropriate
there are online calculators that are
really helpful um the one that i've used
most is from university of new hampshire
it's called elk calc and you can just
google this but that's the um
that's the website right there
you need to know the ph of your sample
and you have to know the alkalinity of
your sample and you also have to know
your target alkalinity which for um
uh for for our purposes is about one we
want the total bicarbonates to go below
one milli equivalent per liter
so that's your target
um
and
that's about it i i think we can add let
me let me just quickly look and see
i think those are all for teary so if
you have questions please don't hesitate
to
ask them i'm going to advance this slide
set for liz
and i'll get liz on here and she can
talk a little bit more about the
equipment
all right hi everybody um i'm a drip
irrigation designer um and i work with
empire drip supply and i will bust to
this real quickly here um typically
the injectors so fertigation is
injection of chemicals directly into
your water line um typically that's
going to be at a really low rate one to
three percent and this is so that you
can achieve more distribution uniformity
across your your system that's a
critical component of all these
injectors they they all work
in that smaller percentage
next
so where does it go this is a question
that i get a lot um from people
typically we like to put the fertigation
system after the fertilizer
or the filter i mean i apologize and the
before the pressure regulator um we
don't really like to send chemicals
through pumps through filters we try to
avoid that as much as possible so we try
to put the injector after all of the
accoutrements that are are prior to the
system
and then before the pressure regulator
because you're going to have some
pressure loss through the fertigation
unit and the pressure regulator is
already set to what you want your system
to be so in order to maintain the
desired pressure you're going to want to
put that before the pressure regulator
next
there are three different types of
injectors there is the basic venturi
style which basically has no moving
parts
it uses some physics principles to
increase the velocity and increase
decrease the suction
um
the
there's water driven pumps that actually
use the water going through them to
facilitate the sucking action this is
really um important when your flow rates
are changing and then there's an
electric one and typically electric
injectors are used with really high flow
rates typically over 100 gallons a
minute
just to go a little bit about the um
the venturi style fertigator that
typically is called or the brand name is
called mozzie it's kind of like kleenex
there's really only one style of them
out there
um like i said it uses just some basic
physics principles it increases the
velocity by coning down in in the unit
and increases the negative
pressure zone to increase suction
through a tube so typically you put the
tube right in your bucket of solution
and as the water is passing through it
it creates the suction action this is
really good for
crops where you're trying to put x
amount per acre on
um
the price range is a lot lower you're
looking at 145 to about 350 depending on
the size of your unit
next
um
this is a little bit more about the the
mozzie unit i'm not going to go too much
into this basically
um there's a few components that you
need in your system kind of tuned up to
make it work and it really works better
if you've got a set acreage and you're
not changing that and the flow rate is
the same
the next are the water driven pumps we
most popular we sell a brand called
kemalizer
it is the workhorse of the water driven
pumps it is a set ratio of one percent
you can alter what is being injected by
changing the concentration of the
solution in your bucket so you can keep
that in mind price range on this is
about
365 dollars this is really good for
greenhouses sensitive crops and crops or
areas where you're changing flow rate
you might have one section that's maybe
a half acre one section that's two acres
and you still want to maintain a
consistent application rate
next
uh the superdose is also water driven
pump
dosmatic or dosatron is another common
um brand this is an adjustable
ratio so typically they're going to be
between 0.2 and 1 or between 1 and 2.5
adjusting on 0.2 increments
these are definitely more expensive
they're going to range anywhere between
500 and 1200 dollars
this is just giving you a little bit
more
fine tuning and what the amount you're
actually injecting
next
and lastly is the electric version of
the fertigators and this is like i said
for a lot higher flow rates we're
usually doing these um 100 gallons and
up where the traditional water driven
vertigators have some limitations so
this can these are size you can go up to
thousands of gallons a minute but the
cost is is quite um high 1500 to 3500 is
usually what you're looking at for for
an electric injector unit they do not
have wear parts like the other
water driven injectors do but um they're
pretty affordable still so you'd have to
go through quite a bit of them before
you'd want to upgrade to the electronic
and that's about it
thank you so much laura and liz this
i was so informative and i just love
learning from you and i think laura was
gonna say something so i'll let you go
ahead
um i'm not really saying anything i was
just
gonna say thanks liz and um
i also wanted to brag a little bit that
liz is the president of the berry
growers association association in new
york state so it's been really great to
work with her and she also is the board
director of the new york state heart
society
and i didn't know this until i was
putting the little thing together but in
2021 she was chosen for the 40 under 40
award by the fruit growers news so
congratulations liz
thank you i appreciate that laura
um
so yeah anya i think we
are good and
ask me questions oh yeah sorry
let's see i don't think there are any
questions in the chat yet so folks you
are welcome to put those in if they come
to mind uh but let's
proceed um is there i think uh liz you
wanted to say something right would you
like to go ahead
well i'm gonna do the annual meeting
here next laura if you wanna share your
screen over to me i can pull up my
powerpoint because the berrygrowers is
extremely important part of our berry
outreach effort in new york state so
don't leave but you could do your dc
thing if you'd like
all right thank you laura um for that
setup so again i'm liz malkoff
besides designing irrigation systems i'm
also the chair of the new york state
berry growers association i've held this
position for the last few years now and
i'm just going to go ahead and give you
guys a review of what we've done in 2021
um 2021 was quite difficult for us
besides all the challenges with covid we
lost um paul baker and that has been
really impactful he was um he
guided us quite a bit in in our
direction and so we definitely are going
to be missing him
the good news is is that we have a new
interim executive director his name is
jim bittner some of you may be familiar
with him already he runs a 400 acre
fruit farm in appleton on the west side
of the state with his two sons kevin and
david
jim's been working really closely with
grow new york farms who's been the
organization that's spearheading the new
farm labor
reform
he says there are many facets to this
organization
oops
apologize and i can't see it because of
the thing
there are many facets to this
organization we facilitate communication
between farmers and researchers through
our fruit quarterly we keep farmers
appraised of regulatory issues that
could affect our ability to farm
and thirdly we work with other
agricultural organizations to ensure
that we understand and appreciate the
challenges we all face i'm excited to
work with people i've known for decades
in this new capacity
one of the most important things
that is affecting a lot of growers
especially growers with employees is the
new
farm labor wage
um act that that was put through last
year we really are asking for everyone
to if they are able to sign up to
participate in the testimonies and the
hearings um they have
done three additional wage board
hearings and there are two more
remaining the first one is january 18th
and the second one is january 20th
we encourage anyone that
can and is willing to
speak at this hearing and you can sign
sign up at this link that's provided
here we also have that on our website
grow new york farms has a toolkit that
will help with your testimony and we can
also help you with talking points so
please don't hesitate to reach out this
is very important
our funding for 2021 the good news is
that we received our full our 260 000
for research we were in the governor's
budget for the second time
we also received our 60 000 for our
organizational initiatives
we also thankfully received the 20 that
was withheld from our last year's budget
which came just in the nick of time we
were basically running out of money
we were then able to reinstate the
operations back to the pre-budget cut
levels
we can't do the in-person lobbying like
we've done in the past years so we're
going to be doing it virtually and
that's going to be coming up here soon
in later january early february
as always membership is critical to
maintain this funding
part of our funding we worked with we
worked with juliette carroll on swd
monitoring network she coordinated with
a few other extension specialists and
growers in new york
and what was interesting is we normally
see emergence of swd in early june a lot
of the traps were showing emergence in
late june and early july which was
different than in the years past so
more research is going to be conducted
to figure out what caused this either
climate weather effects emerging natural
enemies or
some of our spray programs that we've
been doing to combat swd
the sticky cards
were really successful
and you can see in the top right corner
here the heat map basically of where the
emergents were in the counties that were
being monitored you can see a lot of
them say june but like i said that was
late june um and there's quite a few
more july than we had seen in the past
this information was entered into the ag
pest monitor but it's also being
distributed through our blog so if you
guys haven't already signed up for our
blog i highly encourage you to do so
um it is free we sent out 32 posts this
season this past season now this is
during the season and the height of
everything where we're keeping you up to
date on the current numbers and
that we're seeing throughout the state
so this has been very helpful to to many
growers
our funding also supports um our western
new york berry specialist position who
you are already familiar with now so
welcome anya to our team
she i'm sure she already gave a little
bit about herself but she worked closely
with dr marvin pritz in her post-grad
work and that's kind of where um her
name kind of came into to the loop and
we're really happy to have her on board
she's hit the ground running she
actually held a strawberry workshop this
summer or this fall i apologize at
wagner bees and produce in fillmore
on top of a planning tour and harvest
demonstration she also discussed weed
control fall troubleshooting fertility
management and winter mulch application
which are all questions that we get
constantly
you can contact her through her email
here listed or you can contact us or
reach out through
our berry growers
she also is co-hosting with laura
mcdermott um office berry hours and that
happens every thursday from 12 30 to 1
30. um please feel free to join and ask
a question or just listen you can find
the link through that through the
eastern new york
extension website
i just want to briefly talk about some
of our research initiatives some of
these are just some highlights we've
been really focusing on swd
management so we're trying to improve
the adult monitoring by finding more
selective attractants for swd and
they're doing this by looking at
different bacterias and yeasts that swd
seem to fancy
and then using that information we're
testing attract and kill
technologies for controlling swd
we also are looking at the efficacy of
applying chemical controls below the
canopy we found that we can conserve
some beneficial insects by spraying by
targeting swd on the ground specifically
um and we're really looking at
implications for the chemical controls
on beneficial arthropods
last or not last but
we're also looking at a parasitoid wasp
and this has been a really long ongoing
project and we finally are receiving
some larvae
at the cornell
with the cornell research team and
they're going to be rearing those for a
hopeful release in this summer
i'm sure anya is going to go into this
some more um they her and dr pritz were
growing berries using different inputs
and they found that the biggest flavor
ended up being our biggest factor on
flavor ended up being temperature
the greater changes in the cold during
the night and the warm during the day
caused the berry to be more sweet
they also are looking at different
colored shade cloth on low tunnel
berries
and they're finding that keeping the
berries slightly cooler during the
hotter temperatures the summer is also
proving to provide better yields
we
got our berry pricing survey done last
year which was um published in our
newsletters this is a survey we do every
five years just to kind of get a handle
on what the prices are
for berries various berries being grown
in various parts of the state
and a future project is we're going to
survey
um we're going to be taking surveys of
the increased costs that um are
happening due to our labor issues labor
shortage issues and what the minimum
wage increase is going to have on our
small farms we're actually going to be
doing these in person so we can get a
lot more detailed collect detailed data
instead of just like a traditional paper
survey
dr courtney weber has been working on
some promising blackberry primocanes and
they have an earlier fruiting time and a
few varieties of red raspberries and he
specifically is looking for growers who
are going to be willing
to plant some trial varieties this
upcoming season so if that's something
that you're interested in please reach
out to me or out to dr to dr webber
directly and we can get you involved in
that
last i'd like to talk about our netted
blueberries demo plot this was a ongoing
project
there were two
completely covered netted blueberry high
tunnel plots or not high tunnel a high
bush
um
that were
done at dale isla riggs place in
stephentown new york and abras acres in
kennedy
i'm just going to leave this up just so
you can see these pictures here a little
bit this is
um this is the dale isla riggs plot in
stephentown new york
um
we held an open house at both of these
locations in the fall so growers are
able to come out look at the setups ask
the professionals the questions on the
installation these are going to be open
for growers so we're going to be
having more
chances to go visit those in person in
the future so keep an eye out for that
and we're also going to be updating some
youtube um educational videos and fact
sheets on that so that is going to be um
following this
we also set some swd traps
on the inside and the outside of the
netting just to prove the efficacy and
as expected we had a zero percent
infestation rate under the netting so
the netting really works it's expensive
but
um it's showing really promising results
and lastly i just want to make a plug on
why our membership is so important with
these uncertain times we need membership
numbers to strengthen our voice the
greater the number the greater the
impact um
on the constituents and that's what
legislators want and that's what's going
to get us to stay in our budget
our research and development wouldn't
exist without our state funding so all
the information that you're hearing
today
and in the future that most of that is
coming from some type of state funding
so we encourage your friends and
colleagues to join in and maintain a
membership
um
the benefits of membership we have that
monthly subscription of our newsletter
that's our biggest thing we send out all
the information from these researchers
that's developed we send that to you in
real time it doesn't need to be
published officially we send it out as
it's hitting as the information is
developing so you're first to know on
on new emerging information with that
you also get a quarterly subscription to
the fruit quarterly
um
and that is the hort society publication
that is much bigger it's um usually 30
to 40 pages real in-depth scientific
results you're also getting that with
our membership
we give you swd alerts both with a
postcard and an email
um that's sent directly to your address
so even if you're not on the blog we're
still proactively trying to get that
information out to you
you get a free one-hour social media
consultation with our communications
director robin she's really awesome she
knows a lot of stuff
um we get a listing on our find a farm
directory free promotion of the berry
industry through our social media
platforms and representation with new
york state all are very important
so thank you for taking the time to
listen to me here and um if you have any
other questions on the things we're
doing or any other suggestions on where
you think we should go
or research
objectives that you think we should
start to explore please don't hesitate
to reach out we're also looking for a
new
board member so if you know someone that
would be interested in serving on the
board we would love to have them they
don't have to be a berry grower
specifically
but it's always welcomed and
with that i will pass it back to
anya
thank you so much liz
um yeah whenever i hear about what the
berry growers association does i'm just
always floored you have such a long list
of really valuable and important work
and you collaborate so closely with
so many different people with cornell
university with legislators
thank you so much for taking the time to
just introduce
everyone in the meeting or refresh
everyone here about everything that you
do
um
so with that i think now would be a
really good time for us to break for
lunch
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu